-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
-I thought I'd share some of m
favorite #MyDumbInjury tweet
from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one is
from @scarr257.
[ Laughter ]
-Scarr.
-Scarr, yeah.
-Well, first of all,
his name is Scarr.
-I know.
That's what I'm saying, yeah
-He says...
[ Laughter ]
It's like, "Oh, uh, pain, pain
'Joy and Pain,' Rob Base."
-"Arthritis."
-"Limping.
E.R. E.R.?"
This is from @Mander9696.
He says...
"Go get help, boy!
Get out of here!"
-At least somebody won.
-This one's from idgeddes7
He says...
-Leaving a trail of blood.
-This one's from @JordanPhillie.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
-Dumb or the best?
-Kind of, actually.
That's pretty cool.
-If you've got to have a scar.
-Yeah, everyone
likes Santa Claus.
-Ask Scarr257. He knows.
-I know.
This one's from @GregMaxwell85
He says...
-[ Imitates zapping ]
[ Imitates zapping ]
-This one's from
@KristenRose124. She says --
-Hey, Jimmy.
-Hey. Whoa! Hey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Hi.
-Steve.
-Judd Apatow. Judd Apatow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Hey, buddy.
It's nice to see you.
What are you doing here?
-You know, I heard about
your hands,
and I was just worried about you
and I just wanted to
check up on you.
-That's very, very nice.
That's very, very cool of you.
-And, also, I thought this was
an incredible
marketing opportunity.
'Cause, well, I got a movi
coming out, "Trainwreck."
Are you guys gonna go?
[ Cheers and applause ]
And it opens tomorrow night,
but I think you can go tonight
Manohla Dargis loved it.
-Okay, good.
-Yeah.
And I thought, you know,
you're kind of
a human train wreck, right
-Not really, but, yeah, I guess.
I mean...
-And this is a lot of ad space
This is a lot of ad space.
So I thought, because it looke
so weird and white,
we'd put that right there.
-Uh-huh.
-Okay?
-Yeah.
-And now sit down.
-Okay.
-And then,
for the rest of the show,
it looks better
and it promotes the movie.
Look.
Put that out of the way.
[ Laughter ]
-That's the "Tonight Show" logo.
-And then, like,
when you interview people,
just scratch your chin
a little bit.
-Like that?
But I don't do that.
-And then you can fix
the eyebrows
every once in a while
during the show.
-Fix my eyebrows?
That covers my whole face.
-Wait. Hold on a second.
-[ Laughs ]
-Alright, anyway,
I'm so glad you feel better.
I hope it sticks.
-I didn't say
I didn't feel better.
-Bye!
-Bye, Judd.
Judd Apatow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I didn't say I felt better
He didn't even let me answer t
see if I did feel better.
-[ Laughs ]
There you go. Perfect.
-Gosh.
-Make sure it's straight.
-[ Laughing ] Gosh.
Uh, this one's from
@KristenRose124.
-What did she say?
-She says...
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
You just -- yeah.
That's --
-At least the wig didn't start
humping her.
-That's true.
-That would've been weird.
-Or did it?
-This last one
has a picture, you guys.
It's from @JordanRayHalsey
He says...
There you go right there.
There you have it.
Those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
Check out more of
our favorites, go to...
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
-Now I thought
I'd share some of my favorit
"WhyImSingle"
stories from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one's
from @RickyP3rd. He says..
-Oh!
RickyP3rd.
-Yeah.
This one's from @Sweaty Betty.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, there you go.
-No, that's not the reason
-Oh, I'm sorry.
-That's not the reason why
she's single, no.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Laughs ] What?
This one is from
@tidewoddergirl.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
I like this --
-My eyes!
This...
This one's from @Keirstinyo.
-Yo!
-She says...
[ Laughter ]
What?
-"New Brittany."
-You're the new --
You're new Brittany.
-Oops. You did it again.
-Oh, gosh.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @ninjamandr1221.
He says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's kind of brilliant.
-Genius.
-That's kind of genius.
-Yeah.
-[ Chuckles ] God.
-Like a trough.
-Yeah, I love it.
-Yeah...
-Yeah, exactly, yeah.
This one's from
@itsShyyyyyyyyyy.
She says...
He's like, "No,
do you have the date?"
-No...
-Do you have the date?
Oh, God.
-"Date." Oof.
This last one's from
@GrampaBerty.
-Ohh.
-She says...
Oh, there you go. Oh, my God
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites, go to..
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
-Here are some of my favorit
#MySiblingIsWeird tweets
from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one's from @aberlean.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
-She thinks she's gonna
catch him on that episode?
-They had the perfect marriage
Or did they?
-He was living a double life
-It was a fun cruise...
[ Laughter ]
-Until they discovered --
-Until they discovered
the first deck.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @missgreenwalt
She says...
-Is that weird or smart?
-That makes sense.
It's smart. It's not weird
It's smart. Yeah, you're right
-Bleep-blurp!
-This one's from --
[ Laughter ]
Bleep-blurp was what an alien --
-That's what aliens say.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't think so.
This one's from @robin dechant
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
On an all-new "Dateline"..
-Under his bed was a thousand...
[ Laughter ]
...bunny heads.
-Yeah, some chocolate,
some real.
[ Laughter ]
This one is from @bailliepaige
She says...
[ Laughter ]
-She's 38.
-She's 38 years old.
This one's from @BrettAdkison.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
It was honest, man.
-Yeah. God bless her.
-This one's from @JimmyShadwick.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
You just gave away
his secret identity.
-Elmer's glue.
-Oh, this is a good one.
This one's from @MMHarter.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
-How weird!
It looks like
all those presidents, man.
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @godiyperry
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-In some cases.
-That can't be right.
-No, I don't think that's true
That's probably not true.
-No. This last one is
from @wes pace.
He says...
[ Laughter ]
Ta-da?
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites, go to..